"You were meant to
carry his story".
>> Tucker: FUSION GPS
FOUNDER GLENN SIMPSON GAVE
TESTIMONY TO CONGRESS A
WHILE AGO IT.
WAS RELEASED THIS WEEK BY
UNWELCOME AND PROBABLY
UNINTEND TENDED REVELATIONS
TESTIMONY SUGGEST THAT EVEN
AS FUSION WAS ENCOURAGING AN
FBI INVESTIGATION OF TRUMP
AND HIS CAMPAIGN, IT WAS
ALSO TRYING TO HINDER AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
HUH?
LIKE THESE.
HE WROTE "CLINTON CASH."
HE IS SUSPECT OF ALL THE
ARMS OF THE VAST CLINTON
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
PETER, TELL US WHAT THIS
TRANSCRIPT SUGGESTS.
>> WELL, WHAT IT SUGGESTS IS
THAT GLENN SIMPSON DID NOT
LIKE THE FACT THAT THE FBI
THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
HE TESTIFIED WHEN HE HEARD
FBI AND HIS PARTNER
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, THE
EXBRITISH INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER STOPPED COOPERATING
WITH THE FBI ON THE TRUMP
DOSSIER.
THIS IS ALL ACCORDING TO
GLENN SIMPSON HIMSELF.
SO IT RAISES QUESTIONS, YOU
KNOW, ABOUT WHO THIS GUY
ACTUALLY IS.
HE'S NOT THE SORT OF
DISINTERESTED FACT FINDER
WHO IS SORT OF SHOCKED AND
APPALLED BY WHAT THEY FOUND
REGARDING TRUMP THAT HE WAS
ACTUALLY DOING THE BIDDING
OF HIS CLIENT, WHICH AS WE
NOW KNOW HAPPENED TO BE THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
UNDERSTANDING WAS HERE IS A
FORMER NEWSPAPER REPORTER
HIRED TO DIG UP INFORMATION
ON HER OPPONENT.
THAT'S PRETTY CONVENTIONAL.
IT HAPPENINGS A LOT DURING
TRYING TO HELP THE CLINTONS
IN ANOTHER ARENA ENTIRELY?
>> YEAH.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND, LOOK, I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
HE CONTINUES TO USE THE TERM
SIMPSON, THAT THIS IS SORT
OF OPPOSITION RESEARCH, YOU
KNOW, TUCKER, YOU AND I HAVE
BEEN AROUND THE BLOCK IN
WASHINGTON FOR A WHILE.
THAT DOSSIER WAS NOT
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
OPPOSITION RESEARCH IS ONLY
USEFUL IF YOU CAN GATHER
INFORMATION AND THEN GIVE IT
TO THE MEDIA AND THE MEDIA
CAN REPLICATE IT.
THE TRUMP DOSSIER WAS ALL
ANONYMOUS SOURCES.
YOU KNOW, BEARED ON TWO TO
THREE ITERATIONS.
IT WAS SHARED WITH NEWSPAPER
THE FBI AND THE WHOLE
THIS CASE.
I MEAN, FUSION GPS IS TRYING
TO INTERVENE IN A POSSIBLE
CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION, SORRY,
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
THEY ARE PUSHING THIS
PRODUCT THAT, YOU KNOW,
HE NEVER VERIFIED.
HE NEVER ATTEMPTED TO
VERIFY.
IT JUST REALLY SHOWS THAT
WHAT HIS JOB WAS WAS TO TRY
CLINTON.
>> Tucker: BY INITIATING A
FEDERAL CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN NOT BY DIGGING UP
USABLE OPO?
>> YEAH, EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT THEY DID IN A COUPLE OF
STAGES THEY SHARED THIS
DOSSIER AROUND WITH MEDIA
OUTLETS THEN TOOK IT TO THE
FBI AND KEEP IN MIND WE KNOW
OF AT LEAST ONE SENIOR
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHOSE
SPOUSE WAS WORKING FOR
FUSION GPS.
BUT ONCE THEY SHARED IT WITH
LOOKING AT THE DOSSIER.
SO, IN EFFECT, IT'S A TWO
FOR FROM THAT STANDPOINT.
>> Tucker: YOU SHOULDN'T USE
THE FBI AS A COMPONENT OF
YOUR CAMPAIGN.
PETER SCHWEIZER, THAT WAS